gallo la police il ya un monsieur avec
un sac à dos bleu qui veut pas quitter
sa maman
oui il a un débardeur blanc ok c'est bon
ils écoutent maintenant maintenant
j'écoute maman ou pas non plus un peuple
un peuple j'écoute maman c'est bon je
les écoute allez c'est bon il s'est
calmé ne venez pas la police est bon il
est calme et
baccalauréat quand j'étais petit j'étais
bon alors p x country pologne city et
paris animal un perroquet body parts à
un pied un brain c'est parce que sa part
dont famous personne je dirais
patrick poivre d'arvor c'est bien ça
fait jeune
que les fringues je dirais en
un
en pantalon s'évase il gemena un chez
nicole element en plutonium et le sport
je dirais du
salon
rien que je
vois je vois
pas ailleurs
mais qu'est ce que
tu penses que tu gagnes plus entre macro
et nabila
bien ouais et entre nabila et benzema
benzema benzema ok tu penses qu'il gagne
combien peu près bien seulement
10 millions par mois non un million
presque hockey entre benzema et mba pub
à jouer et entre mvp lebron james
le basketteur
c'est pas du vent entre mvp lebron james
n'ont lebron james qui gagnent 3
millions et elle m'a fait 2 millions